hello everyone and welcome back to the
fiji world cup 2021 it's a round five
and
sam shanklin versus peters fiddler this
is their second game uh in the classical
time format and in the first game uh
where spiller had the the white pieces
it was a pretty pretty
uh hard-fought game and maybe swiddler
had an edge at some point with the white
pieces but nothing too serious and in
the end
it ended in a draw now shankland has the
white pieces and
this is well this is one of the nicer
games we've seen so far
uh so without further ado let's check it
out it's gonna feature two really
awesome positive video moments
so uh you know be prepared uh so
shankland with the white pieces uh opens
with d4
and uh you know interest often one
square will make a difference but in
this game in this game it makes
all the difference i i think maybe even
soon two one said such a thing that
inches
one square makes a difference but you
know yeah who would know such things
so here we have knight to f6 c4 g6
and now uh probably uh
svetler was very happy to go for the
groomfield if maybe knight to c and
the knight to c3 and the d5 but we are
in 2021 and of course we have to push
h4 as soon as possible so shankland goes
for the immediate h4
we have bishop to g7 and only now knight
to c3
uh we have d6 now uh and e4 grabbing the
center here very nicely we have knight
to c6
uh and now knight g to e2 so adding more
protection to the pawn here
uh and there is one game in the database
from 2019 from the grand chester uh
blitz tournament in paris
between uh alexander grisham and maxine
vashilagrav
where knight the h5 was played maxine
lost in this game but here's fiddler
just castles
and it is now already as of move six
that we have a completely new game
so let's see how shanklin continues with
f3 strengthening his center here
and now you already realize that the
black white is most likely not castling
king side he's gonna play sound like
bishop e3 move the queen somewhere and
then castle queen side
and then use these pawns to attack bust
open uh black's king side and to attack
and of course uh swiller
will have to attack on the queen side so
here we have
e5 and white of course wants to keep the
center closed
if he wants to attack on the on the king
side
so the five and now knight to d4
uh it seems like this is a free p free
pawn but not really if you capture this
uh then just knife captures on e4 and
you lose the game
uh the queen has to move then the knight
for example can come to g3 and then it's
just really really bad and of course if
you capture it
then uh we we just win the queen so
after knight to d4 we have bishop to e3
just continuing development and now c5
and this knight is now a monster here
so you have to capture this d captures
on c6 alpha song
so captures captures and again you
really do not want to allow
this pawn to come to c5 is just going to
be a better position for black
so here we have to capture it and accept
peter spawn sacrifice
so here captures captures and we have
bishop captures on d4 and now
rook to b8 putting pressure on the b2
pawn as the white king is still in the
center of the board and like we said
the king is uh it's very hard to imagine
this king castle in king's side so
uh makes sense to start attacking on the
queen side even at the price of a pawn
so queen to c2 defending the pawn
preparing the castle and
now c5 pushing the bishop back with
bishop to f2
and now bishop to e6 so getting a lot of
development in
now putting pressure on this pawn this
knight can come to d7 to b6 then we're
going to put more pressure on this spawn
and the white king is still in the
center of the board so here we have
castle's queen side uh we have knights
to b7
the rook here is attacking the d6 pawn
but swiddler goes for this idea all the
same yeah he just wants to attack there
is no time for counting pawns this game
so
knight to d7 and now do you capture this
or not well
it's kind of a too nice of a pawn to you
know
just uh forget about it so here rook
captures on d6
shanklin grabs it and the queen to a5
now and now you can see that
pretty much all of black's pieces are
attacking white's queen side the bishop
is here the rook is here
uh you can maybe double rooks bring the
other rook here the knight is coming to
b6 there's going to be a lot of pressure
on c4
so swiddler definitely getting a lot for
for for his pawns
uh sorry about that and uh here it's
it's a really really tricky position uh
you could so easily go wrong for example
if you try to just develop pieces
without any uh you know any
uh idea of what's happening let's say
you play bishop to d3
uh there's even ideas like rook captures
on b2 and this is just terrible for
for white it doesn't really matter what
you capture with if king captures we're
going to play rook to ba to check
king c1 now we're going to capture back
and white's position is completely
busted
so after queen to a5 we have bishop to
e1 this is the
most precise move and the only way to
defend we have to add more defenders
here and also
and now we are kind of eyeing that queen
there so maybe we can we can use that in
the future
so knight the e5 now attacking the pawn
this way uh with the bishop and the
knight uh and here you could the
continuing
uh in you know maybe with b3 a bit of a
defensive idea maybe h5
but shanklin goes for f4 he says uh well
while this is all very nice and maybe
i'm giving black too much opportunities
to attack
so i'm just going to play f4 dislodge
this knight and then place
play e5 and this will block his very
strong bishop on g7 so here
knight captures on c4 we have bishop
captures that light square bishop wasn't
really doing anything for the entire
game so sam very happily trades it
we have bishop captures and now e5 so
now we've eliminated one of the
attackers
uh and it's time to concentrate on our
own attack so here we have rook f2d8
swiddler says all right that's a very
active rook let's uh get rid of it
we have rook captures rook captures and
now h5
sam continues with the attack on the
king's side and now
bishop captures an a2 if uh white allows
it so
we're just going to capture it we have h
captures and g6
h captures on g6 and now knight to e4
and
this is the critical moment of the game
uh where black is
perfectly fine white is perfectly fine
both of them have great attacking
chances
uh but um as soon to once said one
square really makes a difference so here
uh swiddler played queen to b6 whereas
uh
this is much much different than for
example placing the queen on b5
uh which is the correct idea but we're
gonna uh you know
swing back to this position and see why
this makes such a big difference
because after queen to b6 uh the
position is now
lost for black so feel free to pause the
video here and win this game for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
figuring all of this out because it's
not easy and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's
bishop to h4 this is the only winning
move
and uh well what a movie it is uh the
the the idea is your rook is under
attack and you really don't have a good
um
uh idea of what to do with the rook you
could play something like f6 but
this just you know runs into the
captures on f6 and
black didn't really do anything here so
what you could do is
rook to d4 this makes sense and this is
the absolute strongest move for black
swiddler played it and you are
threatening rook to c4 which wins the
white queen
the problem is white has knight to f6
check and it's just all very very ugly
uh you can never capture and then go for
this because if you capture and capture
and i'll play rook to c4 yes
you kind of do win the queen but not
really because it's mating one
rook to h8 would be checkmate so after
knight to f6
check you have to play king to f8 and
now comes
bishop to f2 and this is just beautiful
so all of these moves are
you know perfectly coordinated and uh
there's just
nothing black can do here uh rook the c4
uh
is uh simply losing because okay you are
attacking the queen
but bishop captures on c5 is the main
idea here and now it doesn't matter what
you capture with
because uh well the queen here and here
is in
range of the knight and now you see the
difference between
placing the queen on b6 and then b5 had
the queen been
on on b5 then we would have no such fork
but now if
for example real captures knight b7
check king has to move and now we just
pick up the rook the knight is nicely
defending our queen and this is now a
winning position for white
so just to quickly go back into that
position now if
queen to b5 now for example if we check
the same idea maybe it will be easier
for you like this
seeing the queen on b5 rook d4 and now
if you go knight f6 king f8 and now
bishop to f2
now rook c4 is deadly there is no queen
on b6 or or will ever be on c5 now if we
just continue with bishop captures on c5
rook captures and the queen still hangs
and now black oh white has to resort to
this check
at least he he will fork the rook we're
going to capture the queen
now queen captures in c5 and now for
example king the g8 to check
and we have two bishops against the rook
this is again uh
completely winning for black so a huge
huge difference between queen to b6 and
queen to b5 in this
variation as you've seen uh so here
uh after this um
sorry bishop f2 bishop captures an f6 we
already shown this line
uh so uh uh after bishop to f2 you can't
really go
rook to c4 and now bishop captures and
f6 was played
so e captures on f6 otherwise you again
run into some very nasty ideas
uh queen captures on f6 but now there's
nothing to be done here
queen captures on c5 check was played
now you're gonna pick up the rook
so rook the d6 only move that kind of
defends the possession but now there is
only one
winning move for white and well that's
all there uh all that it uh
that's necessary so for the second time
uh pause the video and
win the game for shankland while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
uh amazing idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's queen
to c8 with check this was move 30 and it
was in this position that petersfield
resigned the game and
as this is the second classical game
this means that peter svidler
is out of defeat a world cup and sam
shankland is the first player to qualify
for the quarterfinals
of the 2021 fiji world cup so
congratulations to sam
that's a remarkable achievement and
really uh wha what a game to
you know achieve such a thing only 30
moves in a classical time format
so here after queen to see it check you
resign because
well if king g7 then queen to h8 is
checkmate the rook here
defends the queen uh and other than that
you really don't have any more options
you could block with the queen but then
it's just rook to ha to check
wins a very simply king e7 we can
capture the queen
and now uh we don't even have to play
this just bishop h4 and we're gonna pick
up the rook for free
and it's no different if uh after queen
to see it check your block with the rook
it's absolutely the same yeah we could
even capture
but uh you know uh yeah we we could even
capture capture capture rook to ha to
check
and it's the same idea king e7 and now
bishop to h4
will again win the queen for free king
e6 or whatever and now we're just gonna
pick up the queen and that's it so of
course peter sawdus and after queen the
c8
he resigned the game so really really
awesome stuff we'll see what's happening
in some of the other games
of the uh 2021 video world cup
i i think uh some of them might already
be finished as i'm recording this while
they are still playing
uh so stay tuned for more games of uh
this round five
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
yandereta happy birthday grenkey
michael kennedy uh michael calbert and
tom derelo for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of defeated
world cup thank you
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day